let me also ask about uh diversity
inclusion and Equity programs you've
been you've had a few harsh words to say
about those you know the idea of
diversity I think is a beautiful idea uh
you've said that Harvard's idea of
diversity is for everyone to look
different and think alike correct can
you elaborate and be comfortable and be
comfortable yeah first of all it is
impossible if liberal laws education is
taken seriously it's impossible for
students to feel comfortable why because
one of the roles of college is to
challenge all the beliefs that they grew
up with which mostly of the beliefs
inculcated by parents and by Elementary
School teachers
and the idea is to be able to challenge
those thoughts those ideas
and if you don't have free speech and
academic freedom those views get reified
they do not get challenged
so it's it is it it violates the
fundamental role of higher educational
institutions to have any restrictions at
all
that's number one
number two as I think I said earlier if
people students are not allowed to be
frank with one another they don't really
learn about one another
uh and um uh you know I I've given a lot
of lectures in which I have said and I
think people students Now understand it
I'm much more interested in hearing from
the people who Haven and the people who
love me
I'm much more interested in knowing who
disagrees with it and people who agree
with me
that's how I learn and that's how they
learn
The Clash of ideas
which is the theory behind the First
Amendment
that truth will somehow emerge or if not
Truth at least a better truth a true
truth a more useful truth if ideas are
allowed to Clash
especially in the structure of a
university where at least I would say
there's some set of rules some set of
Civility I think I would rather read
Mein Kampf to understand people that
hate there is also quality uh to
disagreement that we should strive for
and I think a university is a place
where when uh disagreement and even hate
is allowed it's done in a high effort
way you know somebody asked me once
about what books I would
what I have is required reading in in
literature courses and I listed my
account
and they were horrified and I said well
it's one of the most important books of
the 20th century I mean six million Jews
died an enormous number of other people
died because one guy wrote a book called
mineconf and took it seriously
it's one of the most important books
ever written how can how can an educated
person not have at least breezed through
Minecraft
and um it's not a great read though it's
not a great read he was not a great
writer but you you do get a sense for
the the sociopath that was Adolf Hitler
yes because he really acted on the words
that he wrote yeah
and it was there and if people took that
work seriously correct they they would
have understood it's one of the most
important books of the 20th century and
if it's Politically Incorrect to read it
it's crazy